[Musique]
on n'a pas dit grand chose et notamment
depuis le déclenchement de l'article
44-3 de la Constitution comme nous
avions déposé extrêmement peu
d'amendements notre parole était plus
que limitée on a vu alors le texte a été
adopté mais il a manqué quand même des
voix dans la majorité sénatoriale une
quarantaine comment vous l'expliquez que
cette majorité sénatoriale et notamment
les LR qui sont favorables à la réforme
n'est pas fait le plein de voix alors
après il faut aller regarder dans le
détail aussi ces voix qui manquent et un
certain nombre ce sont des voix qui
manque souvent à la majorité du groupe
républicain donc finalement ce sont
peut-être des voix qui sont déjà dans
une sorte d'opposition au président de
la République après il y a aussi
certaines voix des abstentions notamment
qui sont vraiment lieu à un contexte
local sans pour autant que le sénateur
dépositaire de cette voie lui
personnellement n'est pas un autre avis
et notamment sur le besoin de voter
cette réforme ça veut dire qu'il y avait
pas de vraies voies d'opposition de
personnes dans votre groupe mais ce sont
dit c'est pas le moment c'est pas la
bonne réforme ça va trop long les gens
qui ont voté contre mais voilà dans le
détail je vous invite à aller regarder
ce sont souvent des voix qui sont dans
l'opposition forte aux différentes
textes de loi que nous avons pu étudier
il y a aussi des gens qui sont
traditionnellement qui se sont obtenus
en qui sont traditionnellement proches
de Bruno retailleux est-ce qu'il y a une
gêne un peu au sein de glace
local qu'il faut qu'il faut prendre en
compte un contexte électoral pour
certains donc voilà il faut aussi
regarder analyser finement on va dire ce
résultat on va rentrer dans le détail du
texte et on va voir quel texte
précisément les sénateurs ont voté
puisque le Sénat le dit et la droite le
dit le Sénat voté sa réforme des
retraites on voit le détail avec Alex
pusard
[Musique]
bonjour Yann bonjour Christine Havard et
Alex qu'elle est donc le texte qui
ressort des débats au Sénat et bien déjà
on peut rappeler que le Sénat a voté la
mesure phare de cette réforme des
retraites le report de l'âge de départ à
64 ans et l'augmentation de la durée de
cotisation pour atteindre 43 annuités en
2027 alors c'était bien normal puisque
c'était la mesure que proposait la
majorité de droite du Sénat depuis des
années et qu'elle votait dans le budget
de la Sécurité sociale ensuite le Sénat
a porté plusieurs modifications
importantes à cette réforme des
retraites et d'abord la surcote de la
pension de retraite des maires de
famille ayant une carrière complète à
partir de 63 ans et si elle travaille
jusqu'à 64 ans et bien ils auront une
surcotte de 5% sur leur pension et cette
mesure est bien la droite sénatoriale il
est très attaché
mesure avait été à l'époque raillée par
la gauche qui voyait comment dirais-je
un vieux réflexe de la droite
réactionnaire d'une politique nataliste
et avec cet amendement on n'a pas eu une
seule voix contre donc bien sûr les
maires de famille on veut les valoriser
avec cette surcotte c'est elle qui
tiennent aussi l'équilibre de notre
système démographique l'autre
modification importante du Sénat elle
concerne l'emploi des seniors le Sénat a
voté la création d'un CDI senior c'est à
dire un contrat qui est censé inciter
les entreprises à embaucher des salariés
de plus de 60 ans l'employeur ne paiera
pas de cotisation familiales et pourra
mettre un terme au contrat au moment où
le salarié atteint l'âge pour liquider à
sa retraite à taux plein et puis
concernant l'index sur l'emploi des
seniors que le gouvernement veut mettre
en place dans cette réforme des
retraites et bien le Sienna a souhaité
que seuls les entreprises de plus de 300
salariés soit concernés alors que
l'Assemblée nationale avait abaissé le
seuil à 50 salariés et le Sénat
également fait évoluer la réforme de
retraite sur les anticiper sur les
carrières longues notamment ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler entre 20 et 21 ans
pourront partir à 63 ans c'était une
concession faite par Elizabeth borne
député les républicains et ça a été voté
par les sénateurs et puis les sénateurs
ont aussi souhaité maintenir un départ
anticipé à 60 ans pour les travailleurs
déclarés en incapacité permanente on
peut également noter des mesures en
faveur de la protection de l'enfance
dans ce texte qui sort du Sénat puisque
la Haute Assemblée a voté un malus des
pensions de retraite sur les parents qui
ont été condamnés pour maltraitance et
puis les enfants en situation de
handicap qui deviennent malheureusement
orphelins et bien elles pourront
bénéficier d'une pension de réversion
donc voilà au final la droite
sénatoriale a imprimer sa marque sur
cette réforme des retraites mais du côté
de la majorité présidentielle et bien on
essaye de relativiser cet impact écouter
François Patriat le président du groupe
RDPI au Sénat le groupe de la majorité
présidentielle le texte qui est voté ce
soir c'est le texte du Gouvernement et
la majeure partie du texte 90% c'est le
texte du Gouvernement aujourd'hui ce
soir j'entends la droite dire c'est le
texte des républicains non il y a eu
quatre amendements majeurs des
républicains qui ont été repris c'est ce
sont des âges au texte que le
gouvernement a bien voulu accepter c'est
un texte de la majorité donc ce n'est
pas une victoire de républicains c'est
une victoire ce soir de la France pour
son avenir Christine lavard d'une
réaction c'est le texte du Sénat ou du
gouvernement mais alors disons que le
cœur quand même de ce texte à savoir le
report de l'âge à 64 ans est un
amendement de la majorité du Sénat qui
est voté depuis déjà quatre ou cinq
projets de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale alors je veux bien
qu'après il y avait 20 articles enfin
donc 19 autres articles qui ont été
proposés par le gouvernement mais enfin
un certain nombre d'entre eux l'index au
seniors
voilà par rapport au report de là je
veux bien donc je pense qu'il faut aussi
regarder vraiment le fond du texte et ce
qui va avoir le plus de conséquences
pour la suite et notamment pour
l'équilibre du système de retraite c'est
bien le texte de la majorité du Sénat
qui avait été reprise par le
gouvernement justement sur l'équilibre
du système ce que vous êtes
vice-président de la commission des
finances vous êtes évidemment très
attentive à ça est-ce qu'il y a pas eu
trop de concessions qui font
qu'aujourd'hui bien l'équilibre
financier ne sera pas atteint en 2030
alors que c'était l'objectif de cette
réforme alors en fait j'étais envie de
présenter les choses un peu différemment
effectivement l'enjeu derrière c'est
l'équilibre financier du système par
contre quand on parle de retraite on
parle quand même de projet de société et
moi il me semble que le gouvernement a
trop vendu son texte comme un texte
permettant de préserver les finances
publiques de de deux sans venir parler
en fait aux gens de ce que ça allait
leur apporter à eux et c'est là où il y
a eu effectivement le bât blesse et donc
comme les enfin on s'y va retrouver on a
juste compris qu'on allait tous être
pénalisé qu'on allait devoir travailler
plus ce qui a nécessité ensuite de venir
faire un certain nombre de concession
pour rendre le projet acceptable
socialement il aurait fallu raconter
l'histoire un petit peu différemment ce
texte il est notamment très important
pour venir permettre le versement d'une
pension de retraite à un niveau
satisfaisant à toutes ces personnes qui
ont travaillé toute leur vie et qui
n'ont pas forcément eu la capacité
pendant leur durée de travail de se
mettre en place des outils qui leur
permettent d'avoir un complément de
revenu à la suite typiquement faire un
investissement immobilier qui va générer
des loyers au moment de l'âge de la
retraite souscrire des contrats
d'assurance vie que sais-je mettre en
place un autre système à côté qui permet
d'avoir des revenus plus tard quand on
ne travaille pas d'autres moyens c'est
ce qu'a défendu la gauche pendant tout
le long de l'examen il y avait pas
d'autres moyens de sauver le système par
répartition et d'assurer des que les
pensions des retraités n'allaient pas
baisser j'ai entendu les propositions de
la gauche et propositions de la gauche
et je taxe de taxe de taxe
un moment on connaît tous enfin on lit
pas les mêmes économistes de l'autre
côté de l'Assemblée moi j'ai entendu
citer un certain nombre de noms bon je
veux bien ils sont économistes enfin à
ce moment là on peut tous peut-être se
revendiquer d'être économiste mais il y
a quand même une théorie de l'impôt
consentement à l'impôt la courbe de la
faire qui montre qu'à un moment quand on
taxe trop finalement le rendement de
l'impôt c'est s'écroule et là tout ce
que j'ai entendu comme proposition
c'était effectivement que des taxes
supplémentaires surtout et là pour vous
c'est un texte équilibré qui fait
suffisamment d'économies parce que
Olivier Dussac il dit déjà que il va
manquer 300 à 400 millions à l'horizon
2030 alors moi j'ai entendu que
effectivement il y a un petit déficit au
démarrage de la réforme pour engranger
les différentes dispositions notamment
d'accompagnement qui ont été votés mais
qu'ensuite dans la durée l'équilibre est
retrouvé et de toute façon il faut quand
même partir enfin on partait d'un point
de départ de moins 13 milliards de
déficit si je me trompe pas en à horizon
2040 donc là si on arrive à c'est pas
satisfaisant et après il y a encore la
CMP peut-être pour venir ajuster un
certain nombre de points puisque
notamment on a des difficultés ou des
désaccords avec le gouvernement sur le
chiffrage du CDI pour les seniors que le
gouvernement chiffre un montant
exorbitant
les données n'ont pas été partagées avec
nous pour qu'on puisse s'assurer
effectivement de ce qui est derrière ces
800 millions d'euros voilà c'est
toujours c'est pas un petit désaccord
parce que le gouvernement dit ça coûte
800 millions d'euros et les LR disent
mais non ça va rapporter ça rapporte au
moins un milliard le problème c'est que
donc là on chacun se sait études contre
contre études et comme on n'y a pas une
véritable confrontation sur sur ce que
enfin je veux dire qu'on a été un peu
enfin voilà pendant le PLF on nous a
quand même chiffré certains sous
amendements à 6 milliards
ça va faire l'objet de quelques petits
contrôles de la commission des finances
parce que je ne suis pas sûr que les
similaires soient là donc voilà c'est on
aimerait bien avoir des doutes sur le
chiffrage il y a des doutes sur le
chiffrage
on vous parliez de la CMP on va en
parler à l'excent cette faible désormais
fameuse CMP puisque mercredi sénateur
est député vont devoir se mettre
d'accord sur une version commune du
texte et oui cette CMP elle est fameuse
mais on va quand même rappeler ce que
c'est c'est la commission mixte
paritaire c'est à dire que mercredi est
bien cette député et cette sénateurs
vont s'enfermer dans une salle pour
négocier un compromis une version
commune de cette réforme des retraites
et le compromis est probable puisque et
bien vous le voyez il y a une majorité
de parlementaires des républicains et
Renaissance dans cette commission mixte
paritaire donc il devrait trouver un
accord sur cette réforme des retraites
même si les républicains l'ont dit
samedi soir juste après le vote les
sénateurs ils l'ont dit on va être très
ferme dans la négociation avec la
majorité présidentielle Christine
Navarre quelle mesure sont à garder en
priorité dans les apports du Sénat dans
cette négociation ben je pense que
toutes les mesures effectivement
d'accompagnement social et des mesures
que vous avez rappelé tout à l'heure
notamment la pension de réversion pour
les enfants orphelins ce qui
une vraie angoisse en fait pour les
parents de ses enfants qui se disent
mais qui va venir
accompagner mon enfant au moment où je
ne serai plus là les mesures
effectivement aussi contre les violences
intrafamiliales il y a effectivement
aucune justice à ce que la solidarité
enfin la société Vienne aider des
parents qui se sont montrés violents et
d'ailleurs je il me semble que toutes
ces mesures là elles font l'objet d'un
consensus et elles ne seront absolument
parmises en question par la commission
mix la commission mixe effectivement
elle va discuter de du CDI seniors
peut-être discuter d'ajustements qui ont
été faits sur la définition de l'index
voilà les corrections qui ont pu être
fait à la marge on va dire dans la
première partie du texte jusqu'à
l'article 8 on a dû faire
l'objet de la discussion avec des
guillemets au Sénat et puis ensuite de
toute façon tout le reste
alors la CMP peut revenir dessus mais de
toute façon on connaît déjà la position
du gouvernement puisqu'il a déjà indiqué
les les amendements sur lesquels il
était favorables il y a peut-être un
point qui va poser problème et entre
vous entre LR c'est la question des
carrières longues des annuités
travaillées par les gens qui sont dans
un dispositif car il y a long parce que
le Sénat dit qu'il en accord avec le
gouvernement que certains doivent
travailler 44 d'autres 43 et les LR à
l'Assemblée avec le soutien d'horizon
disent mais non il faut que ce soit tout
le monde à 43 ça peut être un point
bloquant ça alors aujourd'hui dans la
dans le régime de retraite actuel on a
déjà un certain nombre de différences
suivant qu'on a commencé à 16 ans il y a
eu d'ailleurs une démonstration
intéressante dans l'hémicycle où on
disait alors vous avez commencé à 16 ans
vous allez cotiser 44 ans vous allez
commencer à 17 ans ça ne sera plus que
43 ans vous avez commencé à 18 ans vous
rebasculer à 44 vous êtes à 19 enfin
voilà pour montrer que aujourd'hui enfin
on est déjà sur un système qui n'est pas
équitable suivant le moment il y a même
45 à nickel
ensuite il y a aussi suivant le mois où
on est né dans l'année qui peut avoir
des incidences et qui peut faire qu'on a
besoin de faire une année enfin plus ou
pas donc aujourd'hui enfin chaque
situation particulière euh et puis on
peut avoir commencé très tôt sans pour
autant avoir assez d’animité si on a eu
des carrières arrachées ce qu'il faut à
mon avis beaucoup c'est la pénibilité
c'est pas la même chose d'avoir commencé
à 18 ans dans des dans un travail de
cadre enfin
assis on va dire sans sans et avoir
commencé à 18 ans à la chaîne courbée
dont voilà c'est pour ça que je suis
assez
bon vous vous êtes pour ce qui a été
voté au Sénat oui voilà un mélange de 43
et 40 exactement pour ce que défendent
les députés là on continue avec sur la
CMP et justement vous pensez que ça peut
faire échouer cette négociation bien
cette question des carrières longues et
même aussi le point de sur les CDI
seniors
alors sur le CDI seniors ça sera
intéressant d'en discuter dans le cadre
de la CMP effectivement ce qu'il faut
quand même avoir en tête c'est
qu'aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs c'est un
peu un des arguments de la gauche qui
dit vous allez précariser les seniors ce
qu'on observe c'est qu'il y a au fur et
à mesure qu'on recule l'âge de départ à
la retraite le taux d'emploi des
personnes dites seniors enfin jeunes
senior s'améliore donc finalement
en venant reculer l'âge de départ on va
on va si en tout cas ce qui s'est passé
dans le passé se confirme augmenter le
taux d'emploi des 58 60 ans 62 60 voilà
c'est vraiment les on va dire les deux
dernières années avant la bascule de
l'âge à la retraite qui pose des
difficultés ou en tout cas qui rend
l'emploi des seniors plus plus fragiles
donc c'est pour ça qu'il nous semble
nécessaire de mettre en place des
mesures d'accompagnant d'accompagnement
pour essayer d'inciter les entreprises à
garder ce personnel qui coûte plus cher
parce qu'il faut aussi l'avoir en tête
c'est que entre quelqu'un qui sort de
l'école et quelqu'un qui bénéficie de 40
années d'expérience professionnelle et
ben le coup salarial n'est pas le même
pour l'entreprise mais en même temps il
y a transfert de compétences donc le
Sénat doit chaque crochet à cette mesure
dans cette négociation ce n'est pas une
variable doit s'accrocher pour essayer
de garder quelque chose qui partage qui
cette philosophie de venir accompagner
les entreprises pour venir
favoriser en tout cas le maintien en
emploi des seniors
c'est Olivier merleix qui va représenter
les députés les républicains dans cette
commission mixparitaire ça veut dire que
le signal est fort est-ce que Elisabeth
borne pourra compter sur les députés les
républicains pour voter ce texte et ne
pas passer par un 49-3 alors je sais pas
si je peux m'exprimer pour le compte des
63 députés les républicains puisqu'en
plus à certains moments dans la presse
on a expliqué que c'était un peu 63
entreprises individuelles donc je non
mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que un certain nombre d'entre eux a
largement fait campagne pour les à
l'occasion des deux dernières élections
présidentielles en faveur du report de
l'âge de départ à la retraite parce que
on comprendriez pas qu'ils obligent le
gouvernement à passer par le 49-3 bah en
tout cas moi je le comprendrais pas
parce que j'estime que quand on est élu
de la République on est là pour mettre
en avant l'intérêt national avant son
intérêt particulier et avant de penser à
sa réélection donc moi c'est ma
conception de l'action politique donc
aujourd'hui on est face de Aurélien
Pradier et c'est il pense 3 son intérêt
personnel et passer l'intérêt général en
tout cas dans ce alors il a mis en avant
le sujet des carrières longues donc ça a
permis d'avoir un débat aujourd'hui il
me semble qu'il y a une proposition
équilibrée qui sort du Sénat qui permet
aussi et on en revient finalement à la
question que sous-jacente qui est celle
de l'équilibre financier de la réforme
il faut peut-être pas aller trop loin
ça sera un problème si le gouvernement
est obligé de passer par le 49-3 ça
serait dangereux dit Laurent Berger le
secrétaire général de la CFDT
disons que le vote dans les deux
chambres renforce quand même la
légitimité
démocratique du texte après finalement
votre par 49,3 c'est aussi une sorte de
demander un accord puisque si le 49-3
est rejeté le gouvernement est mis enfin
mis en fragilité et renversé donc c'est
finalement bon on demande un vote oui ou
non
c'est vrai que ça serait dommage et ça
serait dommage de ne pas avoir un vote
sur la réforme des retraites plutôt que
de savoir si on veut renverser ou pas le
gouvernement on va merci Alex à tout à
l'heure on continuera parlé de cette
réforme évidemment on va en parler on va
aller voir l'actualité dans votre région
mais un mot sur quelque chose qui fait
le lien entre la contestation la
mobilisation et votre région puisque on
constate à Paris comme de dans de plus
comme dans pardon plusieurs villes de
France une grève des éboueurs ce qui
fait qu'il y a plus de 5000 tonnes de
déchets qui s'annoncelle dans la
capitale est-ce que c'est de la
responsabilité du gouvernement qui a mis
cette réforme des retraites sur la table
où est-ce qu'il y a une responsabilité
de la Mairie de Paris
alors là typiquement quand on parle des
éboueurs on parle de d'une activité
professionnelle qui est soumis aux
critères de pénibilité je pense que ça
personne ne le nira après il y a aussi
des enjeux de salubrité d'hygiène quand
les poubelles ne sont pas ramassées et
pour le coup l'hygiène et la salbrisée
ça participe de du pouvoir de police du
maire donc là aujourd'hui il appartient
à chacun des Edils concernés par ces
questions de mettre en place des mesures
qui permettent d'assurer l'hygiène et la
salubrités c'est-à-dire des réquisitions
pour vous une fois ou une fois en
arriver là de toute façon et puis après
se posera aussi l'autre question
sous-jacente c'est que aujourd'hui
effectivement d'un côté la grève des
ébouillards et on a aussi des centres de
valorisation des déchets qui sont fermés
trois unités du sitcom et donc là je
veux juste le dire aussi à ces Méry qui
se vendent d'être écolo que les déchets
qui sont ramassés sont enfouis donc on
est quand même dans un véritable recul
écologique puisque quand sont incinéré
on a une valorisation énergie des
déchets je ne dis que ça on va continuer
à parler de l'actualité en Île-de-France
on va retrouver chaque paquet bonjour
Jacques merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
directeur de la rédaction du journal du
Grand Paris on va parler d'un autre
sujet avec vous mais c'est un sujet
aussi qui suscite la colère c'est ce
sont les zones affaiblissement
absolument bonjour madame la sénatrice
et pour faire un jeu de mots facile
c'est aussi une question de report non
pas de l'âge de départ à la retraite
mais de la montée en puissance des
critères 3 vous le savez qui était prévu
en 2022 qui est fixé aujourd'hui en
juillet 2023 et que le président Ollier
dans une interview hier à vos confrères
de France 3 Île-de-France propose enfin
semble vouloir proposer de reporter
après les JO pour des raisons liées
notamment à l'importance du pas puisque
je crois que c'est 400 000 véhicules qui
seraient concernés alors que 70 000
seulement le son par le critère 5 et
puis pour des raisons liées à
je ne sais pas si c'est un jeu d'acteur
avec l'État l'état étant
mise en cause entre guillemets pour ne
pas avoir encore mis en place les
systèmes de vidéos verbalisation qui
permettraient le cas échéant d'exercer
une coercition
à l'encontre des contrevenants qu'en
pensez-vous madame de la sénatrice
faut-il reporter de nouveau la montée en
charge de cette ZF aujourd'hui nous
avons une ZFE et effectivement comme il
n'y a pas de contrôle ou en tout cas pas
de contrôle automatisé dans les faits
elle est quasi inopérante puisqu'il
faudrait avoir un contrôleur à chaque
endroit où on rentre dans la ZFE les
jours de pollution donc autant dire
qu'on ne les a pas donc effectivement et
l'État s'est engagé à mettre en place
des contrôles automatisés au dernier
trimestre 2024 donc ce qui coïncide au
calendrier d'après les Jeux Olympiques
effectivement ce qui est très
problématique alors ce qui n'est pas
problématique c'est la constitution de
ces adefe aujourd'hui la qualité de
l'air est mauvaise l'État français a été
condamné pour inaction dans ce dans ce
domaine donc il faut continuer après moi
ce que je dis souvent c'est que
aujourd'hui les nouveaux modèles de
véhicule thermique en termes d'émission
de pollution ils sont déjà très bons et
en fait si on parle de qualité de l'air
le sujet sujet n'est plus tant les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre c'est
le sujet des particules notamment des
particules de freinage et sur ce sujet
là on n'a pas du tout commencé à
s'attaquer aux problèmes il y a des
solutions techniques qui existent des
solutions techniques qui sont même mises
en oeuvre par des startups françaises
qui n'arrivent pas à discuter avec les
pouvoirs publics donc finalement elles
arrivent à développer ces solutions en
Asie dans tout un tas d'autres pays mais
pas en France et quand je problème c'est
que quand je viens de vous parler des
particules de freinage je ne m'attaque
pas qu'au parc roulant automobile je
vise aussi les métros les RER et les
trains je vous invite à aller regarder
quelques petites vidéos sur les le gaz
qui sort des grilles du métro quand vous
habitez à proximité ben ça fait peur on
parle toujours transforme Jacques avec
cette fois la question du prolongement
de la ligne 18 du Métro Grand Paris
Express
absolument puisque le dernier conseil de
surveillance de la Société du Grand
Paris à
relancer enfin indiqué que les études
étaient relancées vous le savez c'est la
portion qui va de jusqu'à Nanterre qui
va de Versailles là on est sûr que la
ligne 18 va aller jusqu'à Versailles
mais il s'agissait il s'agit de la
prolonger jusqu'à Nanterre sans madame
l'avare vous qui est une experte sans
que le financement soit prévu alors que
pensez-vous de ce prolongement et
êtes-vous inquiète comme vous l'étiez il
y a quelques temps en temps en tant que
vice-président la commission des
finances du Sénat notamment sur le
financement du Grand Paris Express et
sur la probable augmentation des taxes
liées alors aujourd'hui aujourd'hui le
financement du Grand Paris je vais être
très clair il est plus ou moins assuré
sur sa phase de construction des
infrastructures donc effectivement à
l'exception de ce cette petite virgule
supplémentaire qui se rajouter entre
Versailles et Nanterre par contre il
n'est absolument pas assuré pour le
fonctionnement de l'infrastructure et le
fonctionnement de l'infrastructure il va
arriver très vite on est on parle à
échéance de de deux de trois ans et là
rien n'a jamais été prévu et donc ça
veut dire que ça va retomber sur
Île-de-France mobilité qui va devoir
financer ces infrastructures et là on se
trouve toujours pris en tenaille avec
Île-de-France mobilité c'est soit aux
usagers avec une augmentation forte du
Pass Navigo de payer soit considérer
qu'une partie de ces infrastructures
sont des installations d'intérêt
national ce qui était la définition qui
leur avait été conféré au moment de la
loi Grand Paris en 2008 quand on a
réfléchi justement et construit ce grand
réseau de transport en commun qui permet
de faire des radiales et de beaucoup
plus rapidement les aéroports les gares
TGV par exemple à Massy à Roissy donc là
on voit bien que dès qu'on parle de ces
points là on est plus tellement sur des
points qui intéressent les Franciliens
au quotidien on est plutôt sur des
noeuds nodos qui intéressent tous les
français pour pouvoir faire des trajets
entre Provins et internationales vous
êtes quand même inquiète que ce soit les
usagers qui est l'addition inquiète
puisque aujourd'hui le Grand Paris enfin
les infrastructures de la Société du
Grand Paris sont uniquement payés par la
fiscalité francilienne et uniquement
celle là alors on peut mettre un petit
peu les étrangers puisqu'il y a une
partie qui est financée par la taxe de
séjour donc qui a quitté on va dire en
région Île-de-France mais pas que par
des étrangers qui aussi a quitté
finalement par tous les Franciliens par
tous les Français pardon qui viennent
travailler à Paris pour des raisons
professionnelles aussi merci Jacques
paquet merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous on regarde la une plus
bioclimatique un premier à adopté avant
l'été c'est à la Une du journal du Grand
Paris cette semaine merci beaucoup
Jacques Mac et merci Christine Lavarde
d'avoir été notre invité pendant cette
première demi-heure on va continuer
évidemment dans cette émission à parler
de la réforme des retraites on va
analyser le vote du Sénat et on parlera
de la suite au Parlement Elizabeth borde
pourra-t-elle éviter le 49-3 ce sera le
débat du club et d'abord on va cueillir
un autre sénateur à votre place qui nous
rejoint merci beaucoup bonne journée